[Music]
please welcome senior vice president and
director of IBM research Dario Gill
[Music]
thank you
thank you Anna good morning and welcome
to the Ivy and Quantum Summit you're all
looking great it's great to have all of
you here in New York we haven't been
able to be together since 2019 and
you're in for a treat today right we're
gonna share so many fascinating
advancements that are happening in the
world of quantum Computing and we're
going to have an opportunity to have a
great dialogue
I have the enormous privilege of being
the director of IBM research and as the
director of research
um what gives me you know an enormous
joy every day is to be able to work in a
community of scientists and engineers
and designers of every possible
background we have mathematicians and
electrical engineers and computer
scientists and physicists and
mathematicians of every kind and what is
uh what brings us together what binds us
together as a community is this passion
that we have to imagine the new
possibilities with which we do
information technology and computation
it is about combining different
disciplines to push the feel of
computing forward
we say that our mission is to create
what is next in Computing and simply put
we're living in a moment where Computing
with a Capital C as I like to call it is
going through one of the most exciting
moments since the Advent of digital
computers in the 1940s
and what we are witnessing is going to
be the convergence of a set of
Technologies and methodologies I like to
summarize it as bits plus neurons plus
qubits coming together in an environment
of a Harvard cloud computing fabric
and these convergence and the advances
that we are going to be sharing with you
today in the world of quantum
is going to have such profound
implications to our businesses
government to our society and being able
to live in this moment where we get to
see the frontiers of all of these
Technologies is something that I think
we should all celebrate and uh and enjoy
basically every minute of the day that
we get a chance to push this these areas
forward so I want to set the context
before we get into Quantum Computing
because this is going to be you know a
layer of computing that builds on the
incredible technologies that we already
have
the first thing that we all recognize is
that we already have an enormously Rich
computational environment around us we
have the world of public Cloud we have
our private environments we have Edge
environments and one characteristic that
we see is that it's very heterogeneous
in nature there's a lot of diversity of
compute infrastructure and there's a lot
of diversity also of delivery models now
with that diversity comes complexity and
the reality of it is that in this hybrid
Cloud environment we often have to
Wrangle and deal with how do we
orchestrate all of these workloads in
this heterogeneous environment so one
core Focus that we also have as a
company and what is happening in the
world of heavy cloud is to simplify this
diversity the multiplicity of control
planes that exist in these different
Computing environments through two core
philosophies one is open Technologies
and here what we are showcasing is Red
Hat open hybrid Cloud platform openshift
doesn't mean to be able to orchestrate
this complexity and the second element
of it is abstractions being able to have
a more unified control plane built on
open technologies that allows us to then
tap into the power of these distributed
and heterogeneous environment as if it
felt like a single computer so the
vision that we have forward on
orchestrating this capability is to be
able to deliver more choices as more
providers and the full ecosystem that
provides cloud-native services of all
scales become available to us to allow
in our development environments less
time to develop and to bring cost down
through Choice by sixty percent so this
vision is a vision of frictionless
multi-cloud computing is the idea of
treating the cloud and the heterogeneous
environment as if it felt like it was a
single computer
the second macro Trend that we're also
witnessing that builds this Foundation
of technology in Computing is of course
a world of AI and in the world of AI
what we've also witnessed from an
infrastructure and a software
development environment is the power of
specialized compute architectures like
accelerators and gpus
but we've also witnessed that we've had
to deal with also a lot of fragmentation
everything from having your GPU under
your desk to be able to do models to
small local clusters to environments
that you have uh on different public
clouds but the reality is like wrangling
with all of these choices and the whole
stack has been complex so
similarly to what I was describing in
the world of hybrid Cloud we have a
tremendous Focus to create a more
unified full stack environment again
built on open Technologies and
abstractions to enable Cloud native AI
Centric super Computing and what you're
seeing here by combining these areas and
in the future by the way we're also
making significant Investments to create
the next generation of accelerators that
are native to the neural network
workloads that uh you know that are the
heart of AI sort of beyond the GPU
approach when you combine this with the
massive changes that we're seeing in AI
on the topic of self-supervision and
large parameter models or Foundation
models what we are also seeing is that
you can increase the methodology and the
productivity which you can develop AI
pipelines and create derivative models
from those Foundation models by a factor
of 10x and we've seen this recently as
an example in the way we have delivered
project wisdom that you can look at up
to assist the developer in uh in red hat
in ansible environments to be able to
program and assist with the programming
environment as you are doing it
automation
so in this context the base in which
we're going to add now the layer of
quantum Computing it starts with the
realization that bits and neurons in
this hybrid cloud is allowing us to
create these Cloud native AI Centric
super computing
which brings us to the heart of today
the third element of that equation is
going to be enormously profound and this
is the world of quantum Centric super
Computing that is going to add to these
layers
and in this Vision we are going to have
both classical and Quantum Resources
that need to be integrated and
orchestrated the classical resources
will involve everything from the
orchestration of workflows
to a Quantum serverless environment in
which we're going to abstract the
complexity of this infrastructure to the
user and to the developer so that they
don't have to deal with all of these
issues and the ability to create nested
programs and also program optimization
including circuit netting which we will
have a chance to discuss today
now that environment is going to allow
us to tap into not only single
computational nodes where again there is
classical and Quantum orchestration that
needs to happen enabled by KISS kit
runtime as a service but also
importantly to the fact that we have a
distributed quantum network where we
have multiple computational Quantum
nodes that also we can tap into
and we're going to see how this vision
is going to come at reality with a
number of exciting announcements so in
this Vision just like we were talking
about you know bits and neurons coming
together in AI Centric super Computing
we are going to bring bids and qubits
together in Quantum Centric super
Computing so
what are some of the major
accomplishments that we are going to get
a chance to go into a lot of detail
today in making this a reality
the advancements focus on Three core
dimensions of how to increase
performance of our Quantum systems the
value that these systems provide and the
adoption the community that is making uh
taking advantage of these areas and
growing quantum so in performance the
dimensions in which progress is measured
is the scale of the processors and the
systems that we can create the quality
how well they obey quantum mechanics and
the speed of these systems and we
measure them through the number of
qubits that we have the quantum volume
of the systems and clubs the circuit
layer operations per second how fast do
they run so these are the three core
dimensions and uh on qubits we are as
you know from our roadmap we are
extremely proud to be able to share and
you'll see more details a little bit
later uh osprey a 433 qubit processor by
far the largest processor ever created
in the world of superconducting qubits
and is this continuation of the
evolution of a family of processors that
we name after birds that uh we went uh
from by the way last year when we
announced eagle with 127 it was the
first time anybody had built and crossed
100 Cubit barrier so now with uh with
Osprey we've increased that tremendously
and and it brings all of the
technologies that we've been building
over the years including 3D integration
multi-layer wiring being able to
separate the qubit control plane from
from the you know connectivity and the
readout planes so it's a really amazing
tour de force in terms of materials
devices packaging and uh on on the
quantum processor itself and you're
gonna get to see a lot of it uh what
happens and why it makes it so special
but I just could not be more proud of
the accomplishments uh of the team in
making this happen so just to put in
perspective how much progress is
occurring since the last Quantum Summit
in just a year we have improved the
number of qubits that we can create in a
processor by 3x
Quantum volume has increased by 4X
and clubs has increased by over 10x
it is an undeniable amount of technical
progress that is occurring and the rate
on Pace is only accelerating
now in the context once you have better
technology how can you also improve the
entire system and software stack to be
able to deliver more value and one of
the areas that is extremely important
for this uh software stack and value
creation is the evolution from static
circuits to Dynamic circuits uh simply
put a static circuit is like a sequence
of gates where you you know you run them
in sequence in the end you perform a
measurement and a dynamic circuit is one
where you actually have intermediate
measurements in the execution of the
circuit such that you can make
conditional changes on the upcoming gate
execution as a function of that
intermediate measurement
and what this allows us to do is to have
more efficient circuits simply put the
power is to do more with less we have
limited amount of time with which to
execute our circuit driven by coherence
and with Dynamic circuits we can greatly
improve what the quality of those
circuits are and what we can achieve
within the window of the coherence time
that we have so this is going to be
something that is now available uh in
the latest IBN Quantum systems and in q1
we will also incorporate it in our
kiskit runtime environment so again this
is another area where there was a lot of
work it was a key element of a roadmap
to make it happen and the team has been
able to deliver
and on the area of adoption kiss kid
continues to be the leading Quantum
developer platform and and this is a
heart of our commitment to have an open
environment and a collaborative
environment where we can benefit from
the collective advances and wisdom of
the entire community
to give you a sense within uh the
scientific Community Quantum Machines of
course have become a fantastic
scientific instrument with which to
advance uh research here's a number of
Publications on how they have grown
using IBN Quantum systems close to 2 000
now scientific Publications that have
been generating using our systems
you also see the Fantastic growth on
Cascade downloads close to 1.8 million
now and this is one of the areas that we
care so deeply about that we continue to
provide and all of us create value
together in creating this environment
and within the context of Institutions
now of exploring the implications of of
quantum and from use cases to doing
joint R D
um you know on a variety of applications
now the family in IBM quantum network is
over 200 institutions uh are part of it
you're seeing from you know leading
Fortune 500 and 100 companies to
startups you know that are also
pioneering uh this wonderful industry
that that we're creating together uh to
universities to National Laboratories
around the world is a fantastic
community that keeps growing and and we
could not be more proud I know many of
you uh you know represent also
institutions and uh you know and
startups that are part of this network
work and we're so thankful that that you
choose to collaborate and partner with
us
so performance value and adoption are
undeniable elements of wavesource
progress so you can feel this swell of
progress of what is happening in our
industry
it's literally viscerally you can sense
how the Technologies advances how the
interest is advancing and how the
community is growing
now as far as we have come and we share
almost exactly two years ago right the
first development roadmap where you saw
the progress in terms of system
modularity in terms of number and
quality of the quantum processors but we
also share the software stack from
kernel developers to algorithm
developers to model developers and as
far as we've had come we've also reached
the conclusion that for the next wave of
the roadmap we needed to think even more
ambitiously and that we needed to go
back to the drawing board and imagine
the next generation of Technology of
systems and Quantum and that is
something that we're also very proud now
to to be able to share with you because
to enable this to happen
we need a new system
and a new system that is designed with
modularity at the heart of it all
because to create systems that are going
to have tens of thousands of qubits that
are gonna need to orchestrate classical
and Quantum Resources in a new way we
needed to expand the range of
possibilities and that is IBM Quantum
system 2.
and what you're seeing here is how we're
going to bring it to life
we will have a much larger system of
Refrigeration in there such that we can
fit within a single cryostat systems now
that will have even thousands of qubits
within one but importantly the
modularity is designed throughout
not only inside how we are going to
bring together different Quantum
processors but importantly the fact that
multiple systems are going to be able to
be connected to one another so in these
configurations of two and three systems
and in the future even expanding them
further within the context of a Quantum
Centric supercomputer where we will see
connections that range from classical
connectivity to quantum mechanical
connectivity in terms of communications
so one of the things that the team is
creating and designing is the
convergence of communications and
Computing in the field of quantum
this is an enormously ambitious idea of
how we're going to bring classical and
Quantum information with modularity with
very large systems where where
communication and Quantum Computing are
coming together
so with IBM Quantum system two we're
already building and designing it and
our objective is to be able to
instantiate and deliver that first
system one year from now what you're
seeing in here
so you've seen the progress that we're
seeing in the technology on the full
stack you're seeing how we're going to
bring together through modularity a much
larger system that is going to bring us
to that era of quantum Advantage so I
want to close by asking of ourselves
the progress that we're seeing in the
field and how and whether Quantum
Computing is now an industry and I would
argue that the progress
that we're seeing is undeniable and the
answer is yes if you look from a venture
capital perspective and we have a you
know a wonderful collection of startups
in here the growth of Investments that
is happening in both software and
Hardware companies and on top of that of
course we would have to add the
Investments that major technology
companies like IBM are making in the
field as well the progress is undeniable
in terms of the level of Interest the
investment and the talent that is coming
into the field
you're seeing it in the development of
intellectual property and patents in
this space and how it is growing again
the progress in that is understandable
this is all fed by advances in the
scientific Community right of
continuously to think through and create
new ideas and push the limits forward
and you're seeing this also in the
growth of publications related to
Quantum computing
across all of these spaces we are seeing
and we are a proud member of that
industry and to push the frontiers of
the quantum industry for IBM Quantum our
mission is twofold is to bring useful
Quantum Computing to the world
and today is going to be a wonderful
expression of the progress we're making
on that front
and second to make the world Quantum
safe we all know also the implications
that Quantum Computing will have and the
evolution towards Quantum safe
cryptographic protocols is going to be
also a central element of our effort of
our talent and or for Community
Development that is the Dual mission of
IBN quantum
and at the heart
of all of this is a community
is a community Through Cascade and as a
community through or university and
partner Network that we have
and this is the area where you get the
sense that there is indeed this swell of
progress when you see the energy and the
enthusiasm that we all get to witness in
the world of quantum how much appetite
there is to learn to contribute to shift
careers into this new area you know that
we are together onto something really
big
and this is just the beginning of that
momentum and as more and more Talent
comes into the field the rate of
progress is only going to accelerate so
I close by sharing with you what I
really believe in my heart and that is
that the future of quantum is all of us
all of us who are here and this extended
community and that we have incredibly
bright future and you're going to get a
chance now to be wowed by the depth of
progress and the sheer amount of things
that were going to be announcing today